oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre viens je poursuis
mon
très grande révision de droit et au fond
quoi qu'on puisse en penser je trouve
que c'est quand même un examen attentif
passionné et attentif et certainement
utile de toutes ces professions
aujourd'hui dans dans ce monde en
mouvement
mes deux collègues madame
lovagie monsieur Clément on faisait un
peu la question que je voulais savoir à
propos de cet article 21 et notamment
des éclaircissements à propos des
tenteurs de capitaux sociaux dont je
veux pas reprendre la présentation qui a
été faite et de la
véritable fonctionnement
exactement de la responsabilité des
dirigeants de ces sociétés enfin je
voudrais attirer votre attention parce
que je vois ordonnance et quand je vois
ordonnance depuis depuis que je suis
député je suis très très
méfiant que n'attends pas fait avec ces
ordonnances ce n'est pas le sujet mais
notamment avec le droit européen que
nous payons si cher aujourd'hui nous
avons transcrit par Parmentier dans le
droit français par ordonnance sans qu'il
y ait jamais le moindre débat ce qui
fait que aujourd'hui cela suscite une
certaine incompréhension de la part de
nos concitoyens qui est très
préjudiciable que je rate beaucoup je
l'ai dit mille fois à l'époque où on le
faisait par tombereau et aujourd'hui
nous veillons très cher donc je ne
voulais pas monsieur le ministre que je
reconnais vous êtes très sérieux et vous
avez un avenir brillant vous ne vous
hasarderez pas à prendre n'importe quel
ordonnance
à vos orienter vers n'importe quel
ordonnance mais vous pouvez être succédé
par quelqu'un qui n'aura pas la même
rigueur intellectuelle donc les
ordonnances c'est beaucoup plus large
que le débat dont je parle ici attention
moi j'aime bien légiférer quand on
légifère